Les amis, aujourd'hui est un grand jour, pourquoi ?
Parce qu'on vas jouer aaaaaaaaaaah...
*Musique d'horreur*
Ouuuh je l'attendais celui là !
Panty Party !
Bah oui , bah oui
Ca faisait longtemps qu'on avait pas jouer un petit jeu japonais fendar
j'ai dit fendar !
Aujourd'hui on est sur Panty Party !
C'est un jeu de combat
où tu joues une ... culotte
Une culotte, oui !
Eh bah je vais pas vous mytho, il est extrêmement bien noté sur Steam !
Une évaluation positive avec près de 24 évaluations,
ce qui veut dire que c'est un très bon jeu !
Episode 0 : La guerrière de l'amour
Faites moi rêver *rire*
Elles ont des stats et tout...
Ok, on prend la Yurika !
Et ça se trouve c'est super technique
*Paroles japonaises*
Et la culotte parle
D'accord
*Paroles japonaises*
Je dois trouver...
*Exclamation japonaise*
Ah la la ça fait plaisir de retrouver un peu de japonais.
Je dois me dépêcher où je ne serais jamais à l'heure en cours ...
*paroles japonaises*
*soupir
"Wow, une culotte qui parle !"
"J'ai dû me cogner la tête !"
On part sur un scénario.. hollywoodien !
*regarder sur la vidéo*
Oooooh ouiiiiii ! *rires*
Je suis vraiment un slip qui est en train de voler, on joue vraiment une culotte qui vole là.
Oh mon dieu ! Clic gauche et clique plusieurs fois pour faire des attaques continues
Tiennns ! Culotte blanche
Ah je peux.. Envoyer un rayon ?? Oooh ! Fantastique !
Mode passion... Mode passion je suis énervé
Voilààààà
Vieux slip délavé là qui me pète les couilles
Allez c'est fait
On est une très très belle culotte
Je suis en train d'aimer ce jeu. Je suis en train d'aimer ce jeu. Je suis vraiment.. Oui, je pensais pas que ça arriverai
Level suivant !
*regarder sur la vidéo*
Tu parles à une culotte meuf hein.. Pars en courant juste
Allez épisode deux c'est parti !
J'affectionne ce jeu et je déconne même pas
*regarder sur la vidéo*
C'est quoi ce scénario mec ?
*musique de passion*
Naaaaan !
*regarder sur la vidéo*
Bon la culotte Baka veut embrouiller les mecs dehors pour montrer sa puissance
Je vais les démolir.. Je vais les démolir
Oh putain elles sont nombreuses là ! Oh là làà c'est le rush des culottes
Ah elles sont nulles ! Ooh comment elles puent ! Culottes sales, culottes pas lavées
Venez là
Ca sent la culotte !
Mec je me cache, j'suis en train de tryhard
BOOMERAAANG !
Elle est morte, elle est morte, elle est morte.
Bon aller là je vais passer en mode "PASSION" mec
J'ai rien compris à ce que c...WOOOW
Viens là ! On va faire des choses sales
Oh putain elle est vénère en mode Passion mec ça déconne pas
Culotte à pois ?! Mais t'as pas honte d'être aussi laide ?
Arrêtez !!
de me tirer dessus
Voilàààà !
Ca dégage !
et toi aussi on te finit aux rayons !
Y a plus de renforts, c'est fini, là !
Allez, victoire !!
C'est la fête du slip !!
Jeu de mot énorme, hein ?
Ah, y a culotte rayée, maintenant, qui s'incruste...
*regarder sur la vidéo*
Il est où ?
Putain, il appelle ses pantins en renfort, quoi, quel bâtard !
Eh, les culottes à pois, elles sont vénères un peu !
Dégaaaaage !
Voilà !
Oh putain, culotte rayée, elle m'a cassé les couilles, mec, je le sens...
Il a grave de la vie !
En plus, il vient avec un pote à lui, quoi, 2V1 !
Il y a pas de respect entre culottes, ça n'existe pas !
Aaaaah !
Ils sont plusieurs !
OK, mode passion !
Huh, huh, huh, huh !
Il est où l'autre ?
Viens là, viens là, viens là !
Il fuit ! Il fuit !
Mais putain !
Eh, mec, elle est trop chaude la culotte rayée, mon gars !
Huh !
Ah, je l'ai démoli, je l'ai démoli mais on a plus trop de vie, ça va être serré, mec ! !
Attention, je passe en mode euh.... culotte énervée !
*Musique victorieuse*
Oh putain, c'est la fête !
Non, j'ai pas de culotte !
J'ai un caleçon !
*regarder sur la vidéo*
Oh ça sent la merde ça, ça sent la merde.
En plus, on parle de culottes. Donc c'est *paroles incompréhensible*
Culotte Ours !
C'est une culotte de niveau légendaire !
Très réputée pour ses skils surprenants...
Guerrière de l'Amour, le prochain allié que nous allons rencontre est
Ne m’appelle pas guerrière de l'amour Putain!.
A propos de cette allié il a l'intelligence de Panzi et sa puissance au combat et considérable...mais
c 'est une culotte énervante avec une forte personnalité!
culotte Cool Kuma
tu fait trop de bruit. culotte bruyante!
et voila la culotte ours